um so we've heard what gchq have been
saying the head of gchq uh putin
obviously coming up with a very
different story where's the government
this morning
so the prime minister continues to be
very clear that putin
must fail in his outrageous and illegal
war uh in invading ukraine and the uk
government will continue to work hand in
glove with both our us and our eu allies
to support ukraine to defend their
territorial
country borders and to make sure that
putin turns his tanks around and takes
them home
putin still has some friends amongst the
international community not least india
you were there i think in
january am i right and saying and we're
looking to do a trade deal with them
later on but they refused to condemn
what was happening um in ukraine um
they don't seem to as a result be
respecting international borders do we
really want to do a trade deal with a
country like that
so the foreign secretary has gone out to
india this week
to have conversations with
her indian counterpart and to discuss
what is
a difficult situation i think for all of
us who are democratic nations in india
of course is the largest democracy in
the world
that
standing up uh for democratic nations
and peaceful borders which uh ukraine's
have been uh breached is something that
we want to see uh everyone doing and i
know that liz trust will be
continuing to have those discussions uh
with the ministers in india to do that
uh our trade talks are altered as a
relatively early level at the moment and
officials uh met uh 10 days ago for some
discussions which are progressing uh but
we're you know we will continue those uh
for the time being as as we have several
trade deals uh on the go and see how we
progress but it's really important uh
that we see india we understand why
they've chosen to sit on the fence at
the moment they uh you know have
connections in both directions but uh
for us it's really important to see all
countries who believe in democracy and
the rule of law uh and indeed defending
your own territorial borders and wanting
to have that sovereignty you know
respected by those around you to stand
up for that but does it really sit
comfortably with you doing business with
a country that by a mission is
sanctioning the death of innocence
uh so no it doesn't and i think we have
to be clear that we continue to stand up
as i say for democratic countries where
uh the right to live peacefully in your
sovereign nation is something that
should be respected by all and i know
that liz trust will be continuing to do
what it is the foreign office's job to
do to present those arguments and trying
to persuade her colleagues in india of
the merits of uh
giving giving their opinion on putin's
outrage as a legal war when are we going
to um
allow more uh ukrainians to come into
our sovereign nation and get rid of the
log jam that seems to be holding up so
many of them who who need our help most
at this very vulnerable time absolutely
and the uh two schemes are now out and
running are moving in pace i think uh
the latest speakers of the twenty twenty
five thousand uh visas have now been
granted and i know that lord harrington
who has been brought in uh to oversee
this is working uh
literally all hours that god sends to
try and make the process as slick as
possible we have obviously surged uh
more both home office uh and military
support into poland and other locations
to help do the processing uh at pace one
of the challenges one of the things we
have released is that if you have a
passport a ukrainian possible you can uh
do the biometric checks once you get to
the uk which is a great use and a real
help but of course many ukrainians
didn't have a passport they only had
identity cards uh so in which case they
do need to be going to these visa
centers in order to
get a passport to do that so uh we are
continuing to surge into work and i
think it's about a thousand a day now
being processed which is great news and
you've come to the uk um so i understand
that 25 000 visas have now been issued
and i don't have those figures but it's
significantly less than that
significantly fewer i should say so we
will continue to see i think in the
weeks
talk to me about the golden visas i was
reading in my morning newspapers
that obviously the golden visa scheme
was
under labour but it was ramped up
significantly under david cameron's
government basically if a russian
oligarch had two million hands to invest
in the uk just for the benefit of our
viewers i'm sure you know uh they were
fast-tracked to come into the uk eight
of them um now have in the prime
minister's words ukrainian blood on
their hands and they've been sanctions
sanctioned what does that say about the
british government's judgment
so the sanctions scheme that
we have brought in as i say alongside
our u.s and eu colleagues has been
absolutely rigorous we have made sure
that and the foreign secretary has
worked incredibly uh hard to make sure
that all the sanctions bring are ones
that will hold absolutely firm in the
court of law and i think
we have the highest number of
individuals now sanctioned and i think
what's so important now is that we make
sure that we
hold everyone firm on this so there are
some who say
if putin just demonstrates that he might
want to step back we should all start
one another these sanctions are there to
make it very very clear that putin's war
must fail putin's behavior is
unacceptable
and that the financial pressures that we
are applying both to him and to those
who support him who are oligarchs
regardless of where they happen to be
living now cannot sustain their
lifestyles we will not allow that in the
uk well that doesn't really answer my
question my question is what does it say
about the judgment of the british
government when they're giving golden
visas to people who the prime minister
now says has ukrainian blood on their
hands so historic visas have a position
and of course the key point is that uh
in sanctioning we are making a very
clear statement for the for those who
are uh have demonstrated have well they
do exactly those who have demonstrably
not uh you know come in and been
supporters and worked in the uk and been
perfectly legitimate uh you know members
of our uk society bringing as you say uh
wealth and indeed lots of experience and
business development those are being
sanctioned they have been punished uh
for their relationship and their support
of judgment to let them in the first
place
well as we say we know we are now
sanctioning those who have very clearly
taken a position with putin but there
are many who have stood up against putin
and who are here uh and have the you
know the protection and the safety of
the uk because they are uh standing
against putin and uh we commend them for
their bravery yeah talking about bad
judgment 20 fines issued as far as
partygate is concerned 20 instances of
the law being broken so far there will
be more were led to believe by the
metropolitan police the prime minister
is still refusing to say that the law
was broken um the deputy prime minister
will start where you are this time
yesterday morning he said that there
were clear breaches of the law where are
you on that
so the met police as you say kay uh are
continuing their uh review and uh as the
prime minister said we want them to uh
complete whatever it is the path that
they're going to do and the prime
minister has committed that he will ask
sue gray to do a not sure what we're
going to call it a wrap-up report
looking at
everything that he will come to
parliament to discuss it then so i'm
always been in the case i'd rather let
the professionals get on and uh complete
the work they're doing and then the
sugray uh report number two which will
be able to uh put all the evidence that
she gathered uh into the round and
indeed uh for the prime minister to be
able to come and talk to the house at
that point that being said was the law
broken
so as i say the uh prime minister has
been clear that he wants to be able to
come back to the house and discuss this
i'm not asking about it but that's what
that's what so what do you think so you
think so i want to make sure
that uh we let the met police do that
without uh interference from the
commentary they've already said twenty
times twenty occasions they've uh issued
fixed penalty notices you get one of
those if you break the law
and so we will see when the full the
full uh completed report is done and sue
grey will then be able to publish hers
we'll be able to uh discuss it in detail
but as the police haven't uh you know
published any names or any list i think
at the moment i want to let them
continue their work they've told us that
twenty on twenty instances the law was
broken why is the prime minister not
saying that
well because the premise is very okay he
wants to wait for the whole process to
what about you how do you feel about do
you think that they're wrong in issuing
these fixed penalties i have no doubt
that the police are issuing notices on
the basis so they're always broken of
those evidence and i want to make sure
that we can come back to the house and
look at the whole thing in the round
once they have completed uh their review
of the process and that the sue grey
report which i know many colleagues felt
was sort of frustrated by
the met police involvement can then look
at it in the round uh and sue gray's
evidence can be presented so the deputy
prime minister the justice secretary a
former lawyer was misspoke when he said
there were clear breaches of the law no
he is the secretary and he has set out a
position i think if you or i uh get a
fine uh we hopefully pay it and uh uh
move on from there and i hope and i
assume uh that those who have been fined
by the police will pay their fines and
that will be uh the punishment that they
have
why do we get a firm we got to find if
we break the law
so indeed when regulations serve
instances of fines being issued means
that 20 instances people have broken the
law well that's right they've broken the
regulations that were set in the in the
kodak and the police team that that was
what they did and therefore they've been
fined according to the prime minister
not saying that because i say he wants
to wait until the whole uh process of
the police uh review that's been done
well that's the position he's taken but
you agree that they've broken the law
okay uh let's talk about the ochenton
report i mean
i can't even begin to imagine i think my
stomach is splurging stomach lurching in
the awful and we saw some of the mums i
spoke to some of the mums uh yesterday
uh one mom whose child is brain damaged
as a result of what happened 201 babies
died
what should happen to some of the people
that were responsible should there be
prosecutions should people be let go
so i know that the health secretary said
yesterday i'm afraid i didn't hear his
speech but i was able to catch up on
some of it uh that
he wants to make sure that uh those uh
who were responsible for this i mean
catastrophic series of failures over so
many years are held to account uh and
does that look like knowing
will be very firm and they will be
taking the time to look through and
really understand uh the depth of the of
the problems where where there is real
uh you know culpability and where you
know how that is dealt with and i will
leave that to the health team to do that
but i i want to see uh those who are uh
not fit to deliver uh the you know not
delivering the right care to be helped i
mean it's just appalling one of the
interesting things that i've caught
briefly as i was able to look at the
report last night was of course this um
fashion is the wrong word uh but this
direction towards uh natural births away
from uh cesareans at a point and
interestingly as i read it
i realized that when i was in a
fantastic maternity hospital in
newcastle when i had my children
but actually that was that was
culturally normal and actually for my
eldest it was a very very difficult
labor
which you know one has to question it
was that was that the right choice and i
was not given the choice of a cesarean
section at the time which uh afterwards
for a number of reasons might well have
been the best choice and i read that and
thought actually has this been a culture
that has pervaded to the point where
there is
a very serious risk for that relation
with my child that really you know
really made my my my heart sink at the
thought that there you know my children
are well unhealthy and i'm very blessed
but actually to think that there are
many for whom those those medical
choices left families either with you
know as you say uh sick children or
indeed loss of their child uh before i
let you go i just want to ask about
jamie wallace brave young man member of
your party um who has made the comments
that he's made about wanting to be um
transgender um the prime minister
supporting him uh with a tweet but
i just wondered if you if you wanted to
comment on this i'm sure you will um
boris johnson um tweeting his support
but he had also said that the the supper
that he held for some uh members of the
party a couple of nights ago good
evening ladies and gentlemen or as
kidama would put it people who were
assigned female or male at birth that
was insensitive
uh you know jokes made at dinners are
made i think he's i mean all of us you
know the premises know he has a a very
very warm and affectionate personality i
think he is genuinely uh you know
proud and affectionate and wants to
support jamie and his his decision to
share uh with the world uh his his
choice uh to
uh
present himself as trans and i think i
mean he's a lovely young man and we are
hugely hugely proud of him i think you
know this continuing discussion is
is so important but it's also important
that actually at the end they we respect
and love each other uh
as how we want to live our lives i think
that's always what the prime minister
wants to try and achieve uh and we are
incredibly proud of jamie taking on uh
you know what will by definition as a
public person uh be a lot of commentary
about his choice and i think that's
incredibly uh brave and you know we we
absolutely cheer him on and uh want to
want to make sure that he can either be
an advocate in this space or indeed if
he chooses to not want to be an advocate
other than just getting on with being a
great mp that's great too okay we're out
of time it would be good to talk about
that in more detail and perhaps we'll
chat to jamie about it in the fullness
of time for now thanks so much indeed
thank you